based on the series of popular Saturday
Night Live sketches about metalhead
Wayne Campbell and his shy best friend
gasps 1992's Wayne's World was a smash
hit and a cultural phenomenon it spawned
catchphrases galore Schwing Schwing and
put Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody back on
the pop charts
the respectable Wayne's World 2 was
released in 1993 and that was just about
it from Wayne and Garth
will there ever be a Wayne's World three
here's an extreme close-up on why it'll
never happen get the net sequel slump
Paramount Pictures the studio behind
Wayne's World presumably lost a lot of
interest in a third installment after
taking a look at the box office receipts
for Wayne's World - well it certainly
has it's funny and memorable moments it
didn't quite capture the magic of the
original critics thought it was fine but
not as good as the first Wayne's World
and only made 47 million dollars at the
domestic box office which was far less
impressive than the originals 121
million dollar take no stairway denied
it all added up to a lack of evidence
demand for Wayne's World 3 and Hollywood
wasn't going to put up the tens of
millions of dollars required to make it
happen
sister slowdowns after the phenomenal
success of Wayne's World a slew of
full-length movies based on Saturday
Night Live sketches and characters were
released and not one of them managed to
come anywhere near the box office pods
the first Wayne's World earned tone
heads it sparked
Stewart sees his family Blues Brothers
2000 a night of the Roxbury superstar
and the ladies man were all SNL inspired
duds that made a combined total of 111
million dollars in theaters less than
Wayne's World a must by itself the
sub-genre died until 2010 on will
Forte's MacGyver send up macGruber hit
theaters and bombed so overall they just
haven't been much of a demand for movies
based on sketches people can watch your
home for free and that includes more
Wayne's World
getting busy the late 90s or early
north's would have been the right time
to strike quickly with another Wayne's
load movie but Mike Myers was simply too
busy with other projects after Wayne's
World 2 - regrouped and came up with
another over-the-top irresistible
character Austin Powers a British spy
straight out of
and II colored 60s British spy movie
yeah baby yeah the first movie in the
series of Tim powers international man
of mystery was a modest hit but built up
such a huge home video following that
the 1999 sequel Austin Powers The Spy
Who shagged me made more than 200
million dollars at the box office the
third movie 2002 s Austin Powers in
Goldmember did even better making those
movies along with voicing the main
character in the Shrek series and taking
roles in films like 54 and mystery
Alaska didn't leave a lot of time for
miles to do much else family feud the
success of Austin Powers can be
partially blamed for why there was never
a third Wayne's World movie the
character of dr. evil parodied several
James Bond villains particularly the
similar-looking Blofeld of You Only Live
Twice
but his clips speaking voice distant
demeanor and some physical mannerisms
including extending his pinky finger
while talking may have also been
inspired by Dana Carvey surround the
studio impression of the old SNL bus
Lorne Michaels that thing yeah and then
you know when I saw Mike do it I did
kind of go that's along with other
issues drove a wedge between the two
actors who didn't speak for years as a
result of that tiff happily they've
since made up and have appeared at
Wayne's World screaming and on SNL
together health matters
Harvey wasn't physically available to
make Wayne's World three when it would
have most logically entered production
sometime in the mid to late 90s nor was
he able to do much work at all he had
some major health problems experiencing
chest pains Carvey went to a doctor
where it was discovered that blood
wasn't properly flowing to its heart hey
c'mere c'mere look at this x-ray your
heart looks like a pig look at that
thing harvey underwent several
operations to correct the disorder
including a botched operation where his
doctor fixed the wrong artery but have
since made a full recovery
not interested probably the biggest
reason why Wayne's World 3 has never
happened is that Mike Meyers doesn't
seem to want to do it all that much in
2008 Meyers and Dana Carvey appeared as
Wayne and Garth at the MTV Movie Awards
leaving many fans to wonder if a third
big-screen outing was in the offing but
Maya's said he did it mainly to get
caught up with his old friend carve a
three
as later Carvey hosted Saturday Night
Live and the brought in Myers for
Wayne's World sketch that reportedly
sparked something in Myers occurs in
2012 the sources reported that had
written a screenplay for Wayne's World 3
but Maya's team sent out the notice to
refute at all claiming he hadn't
completed a script nor was he even
working on what Myers and Carvey played
Wayne and Garth again for the SNL 40
special in 2015 it's part 2 movie rumors
that Myers good-naturedly shrugged off
when asked by the Canadian Press if
there were more Wayne's World films in
the future he said he was open to the
idea but that we shouldn't hold our
breath explaining it would be an
interesting examination of Wayne at 50 I
don't know what it would look like but
the Eiger of it makes me laugh and Dana
and I had a blast at the 40th
anniversary so I don't know thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're nothing
[Applause]